foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP
3471 object class safe
special containment procedures due to
its close proximity to civilian
populations a covert perimeter around
scp-3471 is to be upheld at all times by
a minimum of three security Personnel
under the guise of historical landmark
restoration efforts individuals
attempting to enter the site without
authorization from personnel with level
2 or higher clearance are to be
apprehended paintings received from
scp-3471-1 manifestations are to be kept
in object storage lockers 4352 through
description
scp-3471 is a cast iron Tramway Bridge
across the river sign in between Trey
Simon and Robertstown Wales the bridge
constructed in 1811 supports an 11.2
meter long deck composed of several iron
plates each measuring approximately
three meters wide alongside the absence
of wear and tear expected from its age
scp-3471's iron brackets and Trust
support beams display no signs of
excessive rust or external damage
appearing to be well maintained despite
its limited civilian presence before
containment it is unclear exactly when
scp-3471 began to Showcase anomalous
properties though the earliest reports
of manifestation date back to 1950 50
years following the closure of the
Tramway
should any individual attempt to cross
scp-3471
scp-3471-1 will manifest near the center
of the deck generally peering over the
bridge railing
scp-3471-1 appears to be an elderly
Caucasian man standing approximately 1.8
meters in height and wearing tattered
articles of clothing
scp-3471-1 also displays mannerisms and
attributes akin to those affected by
significant hearing loss speaking only
through sign language and being unaware
of sounds made in its vicinity in each
manifestation
scp-3471-1 is accompanied by a standard
painting easel a canvas and a duffel bag
all of which materialized near
scp-3471 ones person though displaying
distinguishable facial and bodily
features attempts to connect
scp-3471-1 to any known individual
through facial recognition techniques or
Sim similar methods have proven
unsuccessful notably
scp-3471-1 only manifests completely
when its materialization position is out
of the field of view of any individuals
present however viewing the position
through indirect means does not prevent
scp-3471-1's manifestation
due to
scp-3471-1's apparent hearing loss
subjects Crossing scp-3471 are capable
of passing
scp-3471-1 without incident leading to
scp-3471-1's dematerialization once the
individual reaches the end of the deck
should the crossing individual attempt
interaction
scp-3471-1 initially responds variably
most commonly acknowledging the
subject's presence with a greeting and
or handshake this interaction can
continue comparatively to a typical
conversation depending on the subject's
sign language comprehension otherwise
scp-3471-1 will attempt to relay
information
non-verbally through gestures and
expressions
throughout the interaction
scp-3471-1 will attempt to coax the
subject into standing in its point of
manifestation making sure to keep the
individual from moving from that
position if the subject complies with
these coercions
scp-3471-1 will step back to the easel
and canvas proceeding to withdraw
acrylic paints paint brushes and similar
implements from within the accompanying
duffel bag following this
scp-3471-1 will begin to paint the
subject through differing depictions
with each individual this painting
process continues for varying amounts of
time and paintings produced by
scp-3471-1 showcase characteristics akin
to the impressionism art movement once
the artwork is presumably completed
scp-3471-1 will write a message on the
back of the painted canvas with a
charcoal pencil the individual receiving
the painting tends to interpret the
message as relating to impact full
events they've experienced
scp-3471-1 will then proceed to secure
the canvas with wax paper and string and
will attempt to give the completed
painting to the subject individuals are
capable of accepting or rejecting the
painting the latter of which resulting
in little to no consequence with
scp-3471-1 typically expressing
disappointment or understanding in both
cases once the subject completely
crosses scp-3471
scp-3471-1 will dematerialize
addendum 347101
scp-3471 was discovered on 1227 1950
following rumors circulating throughout
tresinin regarding the benevolent Spirit
of a painter haunting a nearby Bridge
Town locals provided several possible
identities of
scp-3471-1 examples of such include the
impressionist painter Piero the deceased
Town local Dewey and a Celtic water
spirit these possible identities are
still under investigation upon further
questioning Town locals referred to a
high wall who presumably had interacted
with
scp-3471-1 the most frequently compared
to other residents prior to
scp-3471's Discovery Iowa had succumbed
to congestive heart failure dying in his
home on 1109 1950.
testing log 3471-231
test 3471-3101
date
subject d-5681
brief background shot in the lower
abdomen during arrest
results
d-5681 was able to effectively converse
with
scp-3471-1 leading to minimal
interaction the painting received
depicts d-5681 on
scp-3471 leaning on the railing with his
left hand pressed on his abdomen the
message reads the world has a funny way
of putting things into balance through
unpredictable means just remember that
every action will bring forth a
formidable reaction no matter how small
or significant that action may be
test 3471-3102
date
subject d4903
brief background escaped from a sinking
cruise ship equipped with a pen and
Notepad
results
d-4903 was able to more effectively
communicate with
scp-3471-1 despite this
scp-3471-1 seemingly limited interaction
quickly gesturing d4903 towards its
manifestation position notably
scp-3471-1 appeared tense displaying
nervous mannerisms the painting received
depicts the 4903 on the riverbank with
her feet submerged and
scp-3471 displayed in the background the
message reads upon the water's edge is a
Fine Place to Tater for even though you
are safely planted with your hands in
the dirt you are ever reminded how easy
it is to fall in simply remember to
stand back when the water rises
test 3471 231.03
date
subject d-5172
brief background
d-5172's daughter was born during his
life sentence equipped with a pen
notepad and interview questions
results with the notepad and pen
d-5172 was able to communicate with
scp-3471-1 no relevant information
regarding the interview questions was
ascertained from
scp-3471-1 with it once again attempting
to limit interaction and appearing tense
the painting received depicts the 5172
on
scp-3471 with a child resting on his
shoulders the message reads children are
a precious thing of pure innocence and
truth but one cannot always be there for
them do not be saddened for more
importantly a wondrous Soul has been
brought into this world given the chance
to live
note perhaps
scp-3471-1 is purposefully avoiding
answering the questions posed by the
d-class due to their more antagonistic
backgrounds I wouldn't blame it in any
case I'm calling for a few volunteers
from the research staff to participate
in the coming tests from what we've
gathered so far I doubt any of you will
be In Harm's Way so I better start
seeing names on the list
Dr kofton
test 3471 to 3104
date
subject researcher eleanora Mason
brief background father killed in a
double homicide equipped with a pen
notepad and interview questions
results upon awareness of researcher
Mason's presence
scp-3471-1 noticeably displayed more
relaxed mannerisms wherein it attempted
to elongate the interaction compared to
previous tests limited information was
garnered regarding the interview
questions however with
scp-3471-1 attempting to divert the line
of conversation towards stories
concerning other individuals that have
crossed scp-3471 the painting received
depicts researcher Mason on
scp-3471 peering into the water with an
older man standing next to her in the
reflections message reads death is part
of Life coming in many forms and leaving
tragedy in its wake but it is not an end
though The Departed may be gone their
memory still lives on making them
Immortal beyond measure
notes we're getting it to talk that's
for sure but it doesn't seem to be
entirely comfortable yet Horseman since
you know sign language I suggest you
participate in the next test perhaps
through more direct communication it
will be more compelled to share
information
Dr coveton
test 3471-3105
date
subject researcher Piers Horseman
brief background survived SCP breach
from containment is able to communicate
through sign language and was provided
interview questions
results as researcher Horseman
approached scp-3471
scp-3471-1 did not manifest instead a
duffel bag presumably the same bag
associated with
scp-3471-1 materialized upon further
inspection the bag was found containing
painting implements and a leather-bound
journal researcher Horseman attempted to
recover this bag from scp-3471 but upon
reaching the end of the deck the bag and
its contents excluding the journal
dematerialized
afterward
scp-3471-1 failed to manifest during
following tests for a three-week period
after which it continued to materialize
as expected attempts to Garner
information from
scp-3471-1 regarding the absence or the
journal have thus far resulted in
failure
addendum 3471 O2
following test
3471-3105 a leather-bound journal was
recovered on
scp-3471 irrelevant entries have been
excluded
recovered document 347101
the 17th of September 1950.
it's strange to be back here again to be
honest I never thought I'd see this
house again
of course my sister had to bring this
place up with the doctor
quiet and peaceful and full of memories
I wanted to hear she is right though
whether I agree with her or not
she's supposed to be coming here later
in the week
to keep an eye on me and make sure I
don't die in the middle of the night
the things a hard problem will bring
upon you
still I have a few days before she gets
her motherly Hands All Over Me
she's always been that kind of person or
better or worse but enough in the future
something unexpected did happen today
otherwise this entry would be rather
pointless but I decided to take a walk
breathing in the air and getting all the
memories to slow in now instead of later
on this walk I came to that old bridge
where the trams used to run and this
place had some impact on the rest of the
world
there was this old man out on the bridge
looking over the railings he seemed like
one of the wistful types taking in
nature and being at peace with the world
and all that
I'm not quite sure what came over me but
I felt like striking up a conversation
with this complete stranger
and I must say it wasn't very successful
I think the man's death or extremely
hard of hearing the fool only realized I
was there when I tapped his shoulder
he does seem nice enough however gave a
smile shook my hand firmly got a good
uncomfortable look at my face
he tried talking to me in science I
don't know any of it I'm sure he
realized that rather quickly
still though it wasn't much of a
conversation it was interesting next
time I take a walk I should probably
bring a notepad and a pen just in case
18th of September 1950.
it hasn't even been an entire day and
I'm already having nightmares
I knew eventually they would stop but I
did not expect them to occur the night
of my arrival
they were quite terrible as well Israel
even
waking up I could hardly breathe if I
persist Marie won't ever take her eyes
with me and this place
will truly become a living hell
if only none of it ever happened
perhaps then I'd be able to Bear myself
I did do more than wallow in self-pity
Hollow surprisingly most of the food
left in the pantry is still decent if
not partly stale I was able to make
myself some breakfast that was fine
enough to eat I'm sure my sister will
bring some groceries when she arrives
hand-picked Commodities that won't have
me gripping at my chest the moment I
swallow I know she'll make sure of that
finishing breakfast I decide to take a
morning walk like I did yesterday
made sure to bring a notepad like I
suggested and it proved to be a smart
investment
that's how full was out on the bridge
again
this time he brought himself an easel
and a whole bangsworth of whatever
painting supplies you could think of
to be honest I'm surprised someone of
his age was able to carry it all he was
just silently painting the riverbank and
I would assume he's had practice since
what he had done so far was fairly
decent at the very least you could tell
what he was painting this time he
noticed me coming up and again he
greeted me much the same way he did
before
shaking his hands and uncomfortable
looks
what deviated from before however was
that we were actually able to
communicate
I would write down a few words onto the
notepad and he would write some more on
lines of thought were conveyed he'd even
give me a name despite me asking
but he delved into other things
apparently he has traveled the world
searching for simple spots to paint
the fool told me however that it's not
the landscape he comes for and no he
didn't relinquish that information
either
but I mustn't complain really
I don't know the man
yet he has that sort of charm
a light that keeps you invested even
through written conversations
he's old so he's bound to have a few
stories to tell
something to keep me entertained at
least
21st of September 1950.
Marie arrived today
the first thing she does when she walks
through the front door was asking
whether or not I've been taking my
medication
I swear the woman does not trust me to
take care of myself
still she means well I'll give her that
much she was holding on to me though
when I had mentioned my daily walks
apparently walking or any continuous
physical activity whatsoever is not
exactly the best thing for me especially
if I'm doing it alone
she went on about how my heart won't be
able to pump enough blood to keep me
standing
oh how my legs would start to swell
binding me to a wheelchair that is also
something she brought by the way
plan for the future as much as you want
but it doesn't make me feel any better
that you're expecting me to need a
wheelchair
might as well smash my dignity with a
hammer and have thrown the pieces out
the window to be pecked at by the birds
in other news I also saw that old fool
out on the bridge actually I don't think
I've written down anything he's told me
so far I've had him convey a few stories
of his globetrotting adventures through
the notepad
I won't write them all here in this
entry but I might as well transcribe at
least one
actually I'll just attach a page he
wrote it all up here it is
I remember a few years back when I was
in Moscow there was this point where the
pavement bridged over a lower Road and
you could barely see some Basils over
the rooftops
in the evenings the sun would just peer
over the Orthodox spies letting down
slivers of light through the clouds that
would dance with the snow as it fell
a perfect place to paint and I met a lot
of people too
all of them would say stories to tell it
was this older woman dressed up in Furs
that had left a former lover when she
was younger and she regretted it every
day since you see in a strange way that
she herself did not fully understand she
truly loved them up a sorrow plagued her
eyes they mean it so easily away she had
stopped to look at myself painting the
rooftops and as she did the man she left
walked on the road underneath to her
dismay however his arms were wrapped
around another
he had moved on while she had not I gave
up on the rooftops and started painting
her then and I feel in some sense that
seeing that man again gave her the
chance to put the regret behind her
it was a Wonder spot indeed
and I'll never forget it
honestly I don't believe all of it how
the hell would the fool have known what
any of the people he met were home about
if he couldn't hear a thing they said
but perhaps he wasn't deaf then I don't
know still it's a nice anecdote
all more of a reminiscence I suppose
even if it isn't all true
31st of September 1950.
the nightmares are still running rampant
you have to wonder why your brain will
make you face terrible situations during
a time when you're supposed to be
resting and tranquil
it only seems counterproductive or maybe
the mind is just too good at making
things up and no I'm not going to write
out all the regret that's burning within
me for what happened here it won't do
anything anyway so no point in trying
also probably a more pressing matter
my legs have started to swell Murray had
a talk with the doctor before she came
here and said the swelling was expected
apparently that's why she brought the
wheelchair
it could get worse before it gets better
I don't need it yet
and that's not the bride talking
though I must admit getting up is
steadily becoming more difficult
either way I was able to slip out
my sister went into town to get a few
things giving me amble time to have a
walk
of course I went out to the bridge and
once again the old fool was there
painting his heart out
he wanted to paint me though out of all
things I declined of course but they
must admit that the gesture was
flattering to say the least
I was able to get another story out of
him but not much else
I suppose he's just very private on
certain matters and it's not my place to
pry
I've been to France before but it was a
long time ago in fact I used to have a
residence in Paris and it was more of a
summer home on the outskirts of the city
in any case I remember I once went to
Normandy in particular I was in Bayo
there was this spot in its medieval
Center on the corner of an intersection
where half-timbered houses funneled down
towards a cobblestone Plaza it was
positioned just perfectly to where on
certain nights the moon would rise
aligned with the plaza there was this
younger man with curling brown hair and
a longer face he'd been right past me
every morning and every evening on his
bicycle except on Sundays
you see he had a passion or something of
that sort he would go to the cathedral
cemetery and etch tombstones and plaques
onto paper looking for the more offset
Graves that stood alone when he could
then was the etchings in tow
here we go to the town hall or library
and search for records of the person
whose tombstone he copied he'd find out
who they were what they did what they
were like what they accomplished
and what they left behind
I wouldn't say he had a reason for
participating in this hobby of his nor
would I say he needed ma he was
dedicated and through it he found
fulfillment so it wasn't necessarily a
pointless task
that I found made his actions that much
Morely
6th of October 1950. I'll admit it's
getting much harder to walk now it's not
just the swollen legs though they play a
great part in it
I'm becoming short of breath and I can
feel my heart racing as I move about
it's just becoming far too tiring
and as much as I don't care to say it
a wheelchair is slowly becoming a more
appealing option still I don't think I'm
there quite yet
but if anything can happen I suppose
my sister on the other hand has not been
able to take her eyes off me lately
it's not that I don't appreciate what
she's doing but I think she's starting
to take it a little too far
she's controlling my diet to a tea
making sure not a single Speck of salt
happens to find its way sprinkled onto
my soup
in fact it's only soup she's been
forcing me to eat along with a few
sandwiches here and there
she weren't my sister I'd tell her to
bug her off but I can't obviously I was
able to sneak out again however to
participate in walks that I for some
reason desperately crave
to be honest I simply find that a
soothing activity in nature I find it
easier to lose myself in thought and
lost than thought as a very pleasant
state of being
besides I've got to enjoy my legs while
I still can and yes I did happen to find
my way back to that Tramway Bridge it's
not that I intend to go there every time
I take a stroll but it's just become a
part of the root I suppose anyway
the old man was painting there again I'm
not sure whether he's been painting the
same thing and simply has started over
who knows how many times or if he's a
perfectionist
he wanted to paint me again like last
time
I declined though I felt bad about it
he seems rather sincere if I'm reading
his Expressions correctly
but he's far too polite to state that
fact
either way we still Converse oh really I
vented and he listened but I could tell
he was taking it in really listening or
reading in this case
he's the type who cares no matter who
you are at least that's what I'm taking
from him actually I find it rather
ironic he's one of the few people who
truly listen
being there as that person you can
simply talk to but
the fool can't hear a thing
the 17th of October 1950.
it's official
I can no longer walk when I was younger
I dreaded old age especially when we'd
visit my great grandfather out near
Monmouth he couldn't walk two steps
unless he was gripping onto this crooked
cane of his
but he was tired of walking he would
have my great grandmother push him
around on his wheelchair
I can still hear the wheels squeaking
over the floorboards
he wasn't a bad man my grandfather but I
had no intention of reaching the age
when walking became a chore more than
anything
I'll admit I wasn't expecting that age
to be 34.
Charming isn't it
at any rate I think I'm finally confined
to this prison of mine unless my sister
has the desire to push me around the
garden every day I think I'll have to
make do with the porch
you know now that I'm stuck my thoughts
have been racing everything that I could
ever think of has just been popping into
my mind and leaving just as quickly in
other words the roundabout round the
Arctic Trail
I swear I've solved more world problems
in my mind in a single day compared to
centuries Humanity has had to do that
for itself
however it's the strangest thing no
matter what tangent I seem to go off on
I keep coming back to that fool on the
bridge and I don't know why and before
you get any ideas the thoughts are
nowhere near the questionable Natures I
gave up on those Tendencies when you
know what happened
but that's the thing every time I think
of the fool painting the same scene over
and over
doing nothing else with this day I start
to think about him I suppose they're
both similar private likes to make
themselves as mysterious as possible
polite sincere all those things the only
real differences I'd say are age and
looks yet thinking of him just brings in
regret regret and a lot of guilt
actually now that I'm writing this down
perhaps my condition is
punishment
the universe balancing out the many
mistakes I've made getting dark at me as
it were
who knows
but if that is the case
I'd say it's a fulfilling consequence
and I deserve no better
26th of October 1950.
I haven't got much to say in the century
really being bound to a wheelchair
hardly brings about any Intrigue to make
the day more interesting the only
interest that I can get is what I can
think of that and the few books that
have been lying around
found one that I'm enjoying quite well
well enjoying to laugh at starts out
with a church on fire with better Soul
Survivor escapes The Blaze as expected
an arsonist on the loose who has a
backward way of looking at religion and
a deputy that's in too far over his head
apparently it's based off real events
but I hardly find that believable
in any case I realize that I have
neglected to convey one of the anecdotes
that the old fool wrote out for me
during one of our conversations it's
hardly important but I really don't have
anywhere else to put the paperwork he
wrote it all out of by the way it's
something otherwise this entry would be
all about how incompetently written that
book is
and that alone is far too much to write
down in a single entry
many years ago I found myself wandering
the Brooks trickling down the Rocky
Mountains near Montana of course I am
referring to the United States I've
always been fond of Nature and Hiking
was a hobby of mine when I was a younger
man
you must give the states where credit is
due their Wilderness or it still stands
as a sight to behold while I was there I
came across a peculiar but very
interesting spot
it was a clearing amidst pine trees a
bit farther off the beaten path than I
tend to go but I knew I made the right
choice
if I stayed very still a deer or an elk
would creep out from the trees coming to
bask in the Sun as the Pine canopy
hardly lit but a sliver of light through
they made excellent subjects for my
paintings but they weren't the reason
why I picked up that spot nearby a group
of people were huddled up in nothing
bigger than a shipping container
you see they were researchers of sorts
studying a particular natural phenomena
that I myself didn't ever get a look at
they had been sent there and they were
no closer to figuring it out than they
were when they started then one night
one of them had disappeared vanished
without a trace it was a middle-aged ma
older than me at the time and they
searched for him to no avail they only
found his crap pocket watch under an
overturned Stone perhaps something
terrible happened to that man that's
always the possibility though I've come
to think man perhaps he didn't want to
be found after all the Institute he
researched for was too cold and
systematic for his liking
to think the old film I'd have gotten
caught up in some secret government
research operation and didn't even
realize it
write that into a book it would sell a
lot better than the one I'm reading
8th of November 1950
final entry I was going to have that old
full paint me today well I did in a way
I got Laurie to push me out there to the
bridge and everything
thing is
he wasn't there
I don't know what I was expecting really
a man can't be there every day surely
to be honest though I was looking
forward to the distraction however like
I mentioned
I didn't leave empty-handed
on the ground where he usually has his
easel set there was a canvas wrapped up
in this wax paper and tied off with some
cheap looking string
a little note written in the man's
handwriting bearing my name was attached
now that I think about it I don't recall
giving him my name since he never gave
me his
strange in any case I would have torn
through the paper then and there but
Marie insisted on doing it back at the
house
I don't know why but I didn't have the
energy to argue
back to now's we went and my sister left
me to my own devices out in the garden
as she went to fix some sandwiches in
tea
as I was alone it seemed the perfect
time to get a look at whatever I got
from the bridge turns out it was a
painting like I expected
the thing is it was a painting of me
riding a bike out on the Tramway it was
enough to get me to chuckle but not in a
bad way far from it but while I was
putting it down
I noticed something written on the back
of the canvas written in what appeared
to be charcoal
it does not matter if others forgive you
if you can't forgive yourself it will be
painful at first
and the scars will show
but then you can start living again
I don't know but
it's probably some advice you ripped out
of a self-help novel or something but
it's almost as if he knows
and I genuinely believe that I've
regretted that day for so long but you
know what I think I'm ready to move on
that's right I said it I'm ready to put
it behind me or attempt to at least with
these words the regret and the guilt
ought to never again plague my thoughts
and I will be able to live on my number
days feeling at peace with what I will
be leaving behind
but if only it were that simple
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
James Saba
oh crop guy
heroin sec
fire of prime
ND versus the world
Spencer are doing
rubbish ben69
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lemke
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you